I don't know if this is a plumb house
production but I have the strong
inclination it is Ryan Gosling to play
The Wolfman a new Universal Monsters
movie all I know is the title of this
our buddy from the channel who's Nick's
a small YouTube channel does great movie
news videos we're gonna see what he has
to say react to it and then we'll talk
about it afterwards but let's see what's
in store baby my boy Ryan Gosling do you
haven't seen my dear Ryan rap song from
years ago you'll know how much I love
this guy
[Music]
do yourself a favor what's going on
everyone welcome back to the channel and
today I wanted to talk about some news
regarding at universals monster universe
which kind of got rebooted I guess again
with the Invisible Man because before
that universe was trying to build
towards a shared universe of their
monsters starting in 2017 with The Mummy
but that movie flopped and obviously all
their plans are shifted at the time
after The Mummy they were planning a
brighter Frankenstein movie Creature
from the Black Lagoon the Wolfman and
some other characters like the Invisible
Man as well but that was done in a
different project but now after
Universal has shifted their plans for
their monster movies and gone away from
trying to connect them all together in a
Marvel style universe but now having
basically filmmakers take their own
unique vision and put them into the
monster universe it gives them a lot
more free reign to do the stories that
they want to tell specifically and have
it tied down to any specific time period
long house literally same idea miss Ryan
Jocelyn is circling at the Wolfman movie
for Universal Pictures which is being
developed as a star misdirecting sources
tell variety that execs at Universal
have been meeting with directors over
the past month and could be made
question don't tone and who's going to
take the reins behind the camera just at
the time but Cory Finley who recently
received rave reviews for directing HBO
drama bad education with Hugh Jackman
and Allison Janney is said to be in the
mix variety also does say that at the
second event occurred when the new take
on the Wolfman will look like though
it's believed to be set in present times
and in the vein of the Jake Gyllenhaal
thriller Nightcrawler
with the supernatural twist - it hasn't
gone shine is the one that picks this
new take on the real did hear that
Universal was taking pictures from
actors and filmmakers
oh damn we're hearing that more and more
often
actors picking the ideas like Karyn
Kusama
directing a Dracula film I love that is
directing one called dark army and there
was also another Dracula themed film
called Renfield from Dexter flexure the
director of Rocket Man so Universal
definitely seems to be back on track
with these monster films and they also
seem to be doing stuff very differently
because if you saw the Invisible Man
which started Elisabeth Moss and was
directed by Leigh Whannell you'll know
that are keeping in the themes of the
original story but changing things up a
bit modernizing the story and having a
more unique relative angle to the
storyline this time Leigh was saying you
know one of these classic monster tales
told in present day which it seems like
this new Wolfman is going to be also the
idea that being similar to kick
Gyllenhaal's Nightcrawler film seems
like a perfect direction to go with this
joker specifically as well but drop your
thoughts down the comments below do you
think that Ryan Gosling could pull off
this role taken their new monster stable
of characters going forward after they
kind of went for the whole Marvel style
universe where apparently these monsters
were going to team up against some
greater threat but that all fell apart
on a small sense now these rumors are in
better hands and Blum house if you like
this video and you want to see some more
content from me hit that subscribe
button and the bell icon X which seeking
me immediately notified or ever I'm
dropping
you know if you want to hit me up on
social media to talk about the Wolfman
or anything in pop culture you can find
me in the links yeah I subscribe to
who's neighbor thing said I'll catch you
guys next time I know who should direct
this but do you know who's Nick who's
there's some interesting thoughts and
here that are being reported I think you
should read team with Nicholas women
repin for this one haha I feel like for
the mood and also one thing with drive
if you've listened to any of the
commentary behind the scenes they said
what they were kind of going for was a
Wolfman like movie they were saying that
that's kind of the story that they're
especially by the time you get to that
famous Elliot we haven't seen one room
it happens but there's a really famous
elevator scene from that movie by the
time you get there that is like the
Wolfman morphing with tone and talking
about in the vein of Nightcrawler I
believe that was was a Tony Gilroy or
Dan Gilroy one of the dango Roy who
directed that movie the way the
cinematography is of that and neo-noir
kind of style is definitely akin to
something like Nicolas when Raph and now
granted when in referent might do things
that feel a little bit more cerebral or
weird tone experiences but super quiet
characters is money the quiet is monster
movie yeah probably yeah but if it did
only got four gifts together which was
their last feature they collaborated on
but I think that if they were to work
together on this one I think it would be
something very unique and cool drive was
the most studio esque film that windin
refa had ever done similar to this
situation
Gosling got the book for drive and he
was able to select the director and he
selected Nicholas when to roughen for it
so it sounds like he's back in a
position again where he can select a
filmmaker who would be the best person
for this and I mean I don't really know
what the take on it would be I imagine
to be something completely different
again the way Helle Whannell didn't
visible man you know
but I had just won't be a Tom Cruise
like like it's not gonna be an wash wash
the swashbuckler something when Gosselin
has is this opportunity of work with a
director choose or something like that
they go for artsy stuff so if you have
the blend of something from Blum house
or Universal but with artistic merits
like with those kind of directors and
with Gosling and the lead role probably
doing another quiet character and I also
think you should be a practical effect I
feel like you've had great if they could
go back to good old days practical
effects Wolfman that way Gosling I mean
I know he can still do a performance in
mocap but I think he could even provide
more with Wolfman because one thing that
Gosling is really known for is you know
the Gosling stare communicating along
with the eyes plenty of opportunity yeah
with the Wolfman and if you're in makeup
but you still got goslings eyes you can
still get a great deep tragic
performance so yeah I I feel like this
totally would work yeah I wanna I think
it is interesting the way that we're
hearing more and more about actors
spearheading these projects especially
because when it comes to the Wolfman I'm
gonna flub this a little bit launch
Haney I think that was launching jr. he
was instrumental in creating that
character and helping with the look and
stuff like that and so there is a sort
of thrust that comes from him with that
classic movie and even Benicio del Toro
cited that when they remade it you know
a few years back a decade ago in fact
but yeah I think Ryan Gosling is a great
choice just for the demeanor of the
character and the struggle that
character has to go through and I also
think that of all these monster is the
werewolf story and what that represents
that sort of you know monstrous duality
and the struggles with certain urges or
whatever it's a rich territory to
explore even now and yeah the idea of
doing this in a modern-day setting with
a sort of Nightcrawler you're on the
underbelly of society feasting on the
dregs and stuff like that I think that's
a really great take in order to yeah
update it because I think that we've
seen enough period piece Wolfman movies
now that it would be worthwhile to maybe
reimagine it in a new setting what is
the guy who's gonna undergo this
transformation and this anguish what
real life you know counterparts is he
gonna experience I think yeah Ryan
Gosling is an actor who could
a ton of physical body language presents
and whining ref indid neon demon which
is like the closest to an overt horror
film I think he's had thus far and to
see him bring his unique style which
kind of clashes with what I generally
associate with a bus travel to that
field I think could be really cool to
you know different flavor of something
that's a bit more on the vicious side
maybe push referee gory
yeah yeah we definitely and maybe put
push him into something that has a
little bit more of a in-your-face
percolating dread or tension because he
can do uncomfortable to the tension even
in the movies that are not horror based
he can have this sense of I don't know
if the right words McCobb but it is very
like a sinister word is a key there's
always an keeping going on there's seedy
and gross around the edges seedy yeah oh
yeah yeah and I do hope especially if
Blum House has this budget is gonna be a
concern but if there's one thing and I
know people always go was you GI
practical but for werewolf effects
especially I think that to truly make
this special you got to go back and do
at least a practical transformation it's
not that hard to do a werewolf makeup
but to do the actual practical
transformation I think is kind of
important for this because especially
with all the controversy about Rick
Baker with the Wolfman remake having
prepared physical stuff and then I'm
just going with CGI and it was fine but
it could have been so much more iconic
like a lot of the where we've seen so I
hope they bring that aspect and I like
the idea of Gosling being really
involved in the creative process his
best work is usually when what he wants
with the character greatly influences
not just a direction but the screenplay
we've seen that with the work he did
with Michelle Williams and Blue
Valentine we've seen that with the place
beyond the pines who was the director of
the Valentine obviously Drive which
completely steers away haha steers away
from the actual source material and the
way they formulate it was really based
off of the character that he composed
with Nicholas Winton reppin so whoever
he chooses I imagine he'll be very
heavily involved in the development
process of how this care
a foreman going off The Invisible Man
what I think what made that so great was
they made it a psychological horror film
first and foremost and then with the
monster movie backdrop in a way and I
think you could probably be a little bit
more overt with Wolfman that being said
I feel like doing McGowan involved with
a creative process that we will get some
that is it could be weird
and it could be psychological Bay he did
he wrote and directed some movie follow
yours ago that completely was not
received well but it is like artsy
strange yeah I feel like having that
edge but with a producer like Jason Blum
you get something pretty cool huh you
know like those are my favorite he
spliced the two together we get really
artistic people with a producer who can
respect that but knows how to reel you
in yeah proper parameters that are gonna
help the project but keep it in check
yeah exactly and then we get Emma Stone
to play the romantic lead yeah for
seraphic and then we get Russell Crowe
to return again yeah get in chemistry
back from the nice guys all right guys
well what do you think of this report
who do you want to see direct us of your
thoughts down below subscribe for the
real rejects click the notification bell
make sure to subscribe to who's Nick
catch you guys soon